bin laden was not a political scholar
his training was an engineer you know
some biographers claim that he was a
playboy for much of his youth but really
the the these ideas i think
that's probably why they chose the twin
towers i mean this is uh
an imagination fueled by
training and engineering i mean a lot of
the
you know the sociology if you do a kind
of post photography of a lot of these
leading jihadists
their backgrounds are not in islamic
scholarship but actually in engineering
and kind of practical sciences and
professions
medical doctors are among their ranks um
and so there's long been a tension
between islamic scholars who devote
their whole lives to study of texts and
commentary and interpretation
and then what some scholars call kind of
new intellectuals new muslim authorities
who actually have secular
university educations
often in the natural sciences or
engineering and technical fields who
then bring that kind of
mindset if you will
to
what muslim scholars call the religious
sciences
which are you know a field of
kind of ambiguity and of gradation and
of subtlety and nuance and really of
decades of training before one becomes
authoritative to speak about issues like
whether or not it's legitimate to take
someone else's life
with the relation to afghanistan who was
bin laden
milan was a a visitor um
if you look at his whole life course
part of it is an enigma still you know
he
is from a saudi elite family but a
family that kind of has a yemeni
arabian sea kind of
genealogy
so the family has no relationship to
afghanistan
past or present except
at some point in 1980s when he went like
thousands of other young saudis first of
pakistan to places like peshawar on the
border
where
they wanted to
aid the jihad in some capacity
and for the most part
the
arabs who went opened up hospitals some
open up schools
the bin laden family
had long been
based in engineering construction
so it's thought that he used some of
those skills and resources and
connections to
build things
you know we have images of him firing a
gun
uh for show right it's not clear that he
ever actually fired a gun in what we
would call combat
um
again i could be corrected by this and i
think you know
they're competing accounts of who he was
so he's kind of a
i mean these figures that he said at the
pinnacle of this world are
you know fictive heroes that people
you know map their aspirations onto
right and so
people like mulla omar who was then had
of the taliban
was rarely seen in public
the current head held on
is almost never seen in public i mean
there's a kind of studied air of
mystery that they've cultivated
to make themselves available for
all kinds of fantasies right do you
think he believed so his religious
beliefs
do you think he believed
some of the more extreme things
that enable him to commit terrorist acts
maybe put another way
what makes a man want to become a
terrorist and what aspect of bin laden
made him want to be a terrorist
great um i mean let me offer some
observations i think you know there are
others who know more about bin laden and
and have far more expertise in al qaeda
so
i'm coming this
in an adjacent way kind of from
afghanistan and from my circle training
so
this is my two cents so you know bear
with me um i'm i don't have the
authoritative account which in itself is
fascinating because you're a historian
of afghanistan and the fact that
bin laden isn't a huge part of your
focus of study
just means that bin laden is not a key
part
of the history of afghanistan except
that america made him a key part of the
history of afghanistan i would endorse
that definitely that's it i mean you put
it in a very pity pity way um
yeah so listen he was he was a so he was
an engineer
he was said to be a playboy um he spent
a lot of cash from his family
you know like many young saudis
and from some other countries he was
inspired by this idea that there was
jihad in afghanistan
it was gonna take down
one of the two superpowers the soviet
union
who you know the red army did murder
hundreds of thousands perhaps as many as
two million
um afghan civilians during that conflict
it's very
you know
plausible and very you know
completely understandable that many
young people would see
that cause as
you know the righteous pious
fighters for jihad who call themselves
mujahideen
arrayed against this evil empire right
of a godless soviet empire that
when there seemed confusion about what
soviets wanted right now now we know
much more about like what the kremlin
wanted what what brezhnev wanted
and how they elite thought about it
because we have many more of their
records but from the outside you know
for jimmy carter
and then for reagan it looked like
the soviets were making a move on
on south asia because they wanted to get
to the warm water ports you know which
russians always want supposedly right
and it was kind of
a move to take over our oil
and you know to assert world domination
right so there are lots of ways in which
this looked like
good versus evil in congress it looked
like um
you know kind of vietnam again but this
time this is our chance to get them and
there are lots of great quotes uh i mean
disturbing but
really revealing quotes that american
possibilities made about wanting to give
the soviets their vietnam
so the cia
funneled you know
hundreds of millions of dollars into
this project to back the mujahideen you
know who reagan called freedom fighters
and so milan was part of that universe
he's part of that you know he's swimming
in the ocean of these
afghan mujahideen who out of size you
know that did 95 of the fighting they're
the ones who died they're the ones who
defeated the red army right the arabs
that were there did a little fighting
but a lot of it was for
you know their purposes it was to get
experience it was to
kind of create their reputations like
bin laden began to force himself
of being spoken for a global project
because by the late 80s
when bin laden i think was more active
and began
conspiring with people from other arab
countries
the idea that
you know gorbachev came to power in 85
he's like let's get out of here this is
this is draining the soviet budget it's
an embarrassment
uh we didn't think about this properly
let's focus on restoring
um the party
and strengthening the soviet union
let's get out of this costly war you
know it's it's a waste it's not worth it
we don't lose anything by getting out of
afghanistan
um and so their retreat was quite
uh effective and successful from the
soviet point of view right it's not what
we're seeing now
what year was the retreat um i mean it
began so mikhail gorbachev came to
pioneer 285 you know he was a generation
younger than the other guys
he was a critic of the system
he didn't want to abolish it he wanted
to reform it
he was a true believer in in soviet
socialism and in the in the party as a
you know
a monopolist right
um but he's critical of the old guard
and recognized that
the party had to change and the whole
system had to change to continue to
compete
and so afghanistan was one element of
this
and so he
pushed
the afghan elites that moscow was
backing
to basically say listen we're going to
share power um and so
i figured najibullah
who was a soviet trained
intelligence specialist sitting in kabul
agreed and he said we need to have a
more kind of pluralistic
accommodations approach to our enemies
who are
backed by the us mainly sitting in
pakistan sitting in iran
backed by these areas to degree getting
money from saudi
and he said let's draw some of them into
the government and
basically have a kind of unity
government that makes some space the
opposition
and for the most part with u.s backing
with pakistani backing with iranian
backing and with saudi backing the
opposition said no we're not going to
reconcile we're going to push you off
the cliff and so that story goes on from
at least 1987
the last soviet red army troops leave
early 1989
um but the nigeria government
holds on for three more years
it is the um i mean they're still
getting some help from the soviet union
its enemies are still getting help from
the u.s mainly
and um it's not 1992 that that um that
they lose
and then the mujahideen come to power
they immediately you know they're deeply
fractured and that's where bin laden is
watching all of this unroll that's right
and he's he's part of the makes but he's
also mobile so he he at one point you
know goes um
you know he's in sudan you know he's
he's moving from place to place his
people are all over the world in fact
they i mean if you think of the
once the mujahideen take power
you know they have difficulties with
arab fighters too and they don't want
them coming in and you know messing with
mujahideen regardless as like you know
this is an afghan national state that
we're going to build it's going to be
islamic it's going to be an islamic
state
but
you can't interfere with us and so
there are always tensions and so the
arabs are always kind of i would say
they were
their fighters were always interlopers
um yes the afghans are happy to take
their money
send patients their hospitals
um take their weapons but
they're never gonna let this be like a
saudi or egyptian or whatever project
um but then many of those fighters went
home
they went back to syria they were back
to egypt
some wanted to go back to saudi arabia
but the saudis are very careful i mean
the saudis always used afghanistan as a
kind of safety valve
in fact they had you know fundraisers on
television
they chartered jets they filled them
with people to fly to pakistan um
get out into the shower and say you know
go fight and it was one way that the the
monarchy the saudi monarchy
um
very cleverly i think created a
kind of escape valve for would-be
dissidents in saudi arabia right just
send them abroad you want to fight jihad
go do that somewhere else don't don't
bother the kingdom
but all this became dicier um
in the early 90s when some of these guys
came back home
and some of the scholars around them
said you know let's we've defeated the
soviet union which is a huge huge boost
i think part of the dynamic we see today
is that
the taliban victory
is a renewed inspiration for people who
think look
we beat the soviets now we beat the
americans
and so already
watching the soviet retreat across this
bridge back into uzbekistan if you see
these dramatic images of the tanks you
know moving
a lot of people interpreted this as like
you know we are going to change the
world
and now we're turning to the americans
and our our local national governments
are backed by the americans so let's
start with some of those places and then
let's go strike let's go strike you know
the bell of the beast which is america
which is new york
and going back to midland you're
questioning about you know what
motivates him
what motivated him
you know again he was not
a
rigorously trained islamic scholar
and that i think you know when i when
this when this comes up in our classes
you know i think especially young people
i mean people weren't even born i mean
they're shocked they see they see his
appearance they see
him pictured
in front of a
giant bookshelf of arabic books he's got
the klashnikov
he's got what looks like a religious
scholars library behind him right
but if you look at his
words i mean one fascinating thing about
just our politics and just one thing
that kind of sums us up i mean
the fact that on 9 11 we had to have
a few people
a few experts
people like bernie rubin who was an
afghanistan expert so that was one way
in which i think you know i'm not
faulting him personally but it's just
one way in which that relationship
appeared to be you know
formed right of linking afghanistan to
that moment
um
if one looks actually you know what bin
laden was saying and doing
people like richard clark were studying
this
there were arab leaders the arab press
was watching this because he gave some
of his first interviews to
a few arab
newspaper outlets
but speaking of our american kind of you
know monolingualism
a lot of what you're saying wasn't known
and so i think
for several years
people weren't reading what bin laden
said i mean experts are reading reading
it in arabic
but there was great anxiety around
transcending his works so you know we
have my conf we have all this other
stuff you can buy the collector works of
lennon stalin mao whatever you want in
whatever language you want
but bin laden was taboo for american
publishing so it was only a
verso in the uk
that published
a famous volume called messages to the
world
which was the first convenient
compendium of of banan's writings so he
has a mineconf
he has a type does he have a thing it
means the kind of collected works it's
the collected works okay of his
like a blog
like yeah it's a collection of articles
versus yeah these are interviews these
are his his missives his his decorations
his um
his decrees right um but i think just in
terms of if we zoom out for a second
about you know american policy choices
and so on the powers that be didn't
trust us to know what he was really
about i put it that way and i don't see
that in a conspiratorial sense i just
think that it was
you know it was a taboo i think people
you know there was a kind of consensus
that um
you know trust us we know we know how to
fight al qaeda
and you don't need to know what they're
about because they're they're crazy
they're they're fanatics they're
fundamentalists they hate us remember
that language yeah uh it's us versus
them
but if you read bin laden that's when it
gets messy that's where
the bin laden's argumentation is not
fundamentally
about islam
and if were sitting here with islamic
scholar he would say
you know depending on which islamic
scholar they would tend to go through
and dissect
and negate
you know 99 of the arguments that milan
claimed was in islam right but what
strikes me as an historian who's again
looking at this adjacently
um if you read bin laden i mean the
arguments they make
are
first of all they're sophisticated
they reflect
a
mind that
is about geopolitics
he uses terms like imperialism
he knows something about world history
he knows something about geography so
imperialism is the enemy former what's
the nature of the enemy it's it's a it's
an amalgam and
he like a good politician which is what
i would call him
he
is adept at speaking
in different ways to different audiences
so if you look at
the context in which he speaks if you
look at messages to the world
if you look at his writings and it would
zoom out now and we now have compendia
of the writings of al qaeda more broadly
you can purchase these
you know
they're basically primary source
collections
um
we now have that for the taliban i mean
what's fascinating about
i think
if you like this culture acknowledging
it's very
you know diverse internally
is that
these people are
representatives of political movements
who seek followers they speak they often
are very
i'd say skilled at
at visual imagery and especially now i
mean what's fascinating is that i mean
the taliban used to shoot televisions
they used to you know blow up
vcr um you know videotapes um
they used to string
audio and video cassettes from trees and
kind of ceremonial hangings right that
were we're killing this nefarious
infidel technology that is doing the
work of satan and yet today
at last i mean one of the keys to the
top on success is that they got really
good at using media
i mean brilliant at using
uh
the written word the spoken word music
actually um and
you know hollywood hollywood is the gold
standard and these guys have studied how
to create drama
how to speak to modern users i mean
islamic state did this i mean the role
of media new media i mean i am i follow
and i am followed by
senior top on leaders which is
you know bizarre you know on twitter
twitter i don't know why they care about
me i'm i'm nothing uh they f their fault
they follow you on twitter i don't know
why this is no joke this is no joke so
it's they're part of our modern world
and how they talk and it's how they
recruit and this is part of the this is
why they are you know so so bin laden if
you're bin laden he
he speaks multiple languages i would say
it's uh
it's environmentalism
you know the west is bad because we
destroyed the planet the west is bad
because we abuse women
so in class you know
especially you know female students
are very surprised to learn and actually
say you know this this feminist argument
is not
you know we start with you know this is
a murder
this is a person who has taken human
life innocent life over and over again
and he is um
you know
aspirationally genocidal
but let's try to understand what he's
about so we walk through the text read
them and people are
shocked to learn that
it's not just about
you know quotations in the quran strung
together in some irrational fashion
he knows um
i mean the core i'd say is the problem
of human suffering
and he has a geography of that that is
mostly muslim but he talks about the
suffering of kashmir all right so if you
have a student in your class
who's from south asia who knows about
kashmir
you know he or she will say
that's not entirely inaccurate you know
the indian state commits atrocities in
kashmir
uh you know pakistan is doing that too
you know palestine is an issue right so
you have
an american university setting people
across the spectrum who
get that you know palestinians have had
a raw deal
and so it's a
victimhood is essential and it's
muslim victimhood which is primary
but
as number scholars have written and i'm
you know i i definitely think this is a
a framework for what this useful i mean
in this kind of vocabulary in the same
in this framing this narrative um
today in today's world if you think of
today's world being
post-cold war
91 to the present
looking at the series of gulf wars
and seeing the visuals of that i think
that you know i think the american
public has been shielded from this but
if you look at you know
the carnage of the iraqi army
that
george h.w bush produced right or you
think of you know the images of the
suffering of
iraqi children under george h.w bush's
sanctions u.s british airstrikes
then you have madeleine albright
answer a question on 16 minutes saying
do you think you know the deaths of
half a million iraqi kids is is worth it
he was that justified to contain saam
hussein
and she says on camera yes that it's
worth it to me
if you put that all together
i mean american kids and of course the
american public
they're not always aware of those those
facts of global history
but these guys are
and they they very
capably
use these images use these tropes
and use facts i mean in fact i mean some
things are not are not deniable i mean
the
i mean these estimates about the number
of iraqi civilian children dead you know
that that came from i think the lancet
and it came from yeah those are those
are estimates but looking at this one
point of view of
of amman
of you know jaffa of
nairobi you just think around the planet
if you see yourself as the victim of
this
great imperial power
you know you see why especially young
men would be drawn to
a road of
of self-sacrifice
and the idea is that
in in killing others
you are
making
them feel how you feel
yeah because they won't listen to your
arguments reasonably because they won't
you know recognize palestinian suffering
bosnian suffering right chechen
suffering
you go across the planet right because
they don't recognize our suffering
we're going to speak to you in the only
language you understand and that's
violence
and look at the violence of of the
post-1991
world right in which american air power
really
becomes a global you know kind of
fact in the lives of so many people
um and then the big mistake after 9 11
among many i mean fundamentally was
taking the war on terror
to some you know 30 or 40 countries
right so that you have a
more and more of the globe feel like
they're under attack right
and then the logic is essentially it's
not it's not it's rebirth and it's not
we're going to
convert you and turn you into muslims
and that's why we're doing this that
that appears that claim does appear at
times
but it's if you look at any given bin
laden text i mean there are 40 claims in
each text i mean it's kind of it's
dizzying but
he's a modern politician he knows the
language of
of social equality
you know that there's a class dimension
to it there is an environmental
dimension to it there's a gender
dimension to it
and yes there are chronic quotes
sprinkled in
and when he wants to speak that language
he knew that you know he's not a scholar
so he would often get
a few recognized scholars to sign on so
some of his decorations of jihad
had his signature kind of sprinkled in
with like a dozen other other signatures
from
people who are somewhat known or at
least you know with titles right
um so as a kind of intellectual exercise
it's fascinating to see that
he is throwing everything at the wall in
one level
um that's one way to see that it's a
it's a these are kind of testaments
toward recruitment
of people who
yes they're angry yes they're unhappy
and this is what you know i think
for a broader public it's hard to get
you're like well bin laden didn't suffer
he wasn't poor
like yeah i mean
linen
pol pot i mean they're speaking to
they're empathetic to the suffering the
landscape the full landscape of
something it's interesting to
think about suffering
you know america
the american public american politicians
and leaders
when they see what is good and evil
they are often not empathetic to the
suffering of others and
what you're saying is bin laden
perhaps accurately could speak to the
ignorance of america maybe the soviet
union to the suffering of their people
you